قالت الصين لان قوات بحريه وجويه روسيه
ستشارك في تدريبات مشتركه بين البلدين
ستجرى في الجزء الاوسط من بحر اليابان كان
ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه
مسارات ما رسائل المناوره الصينيه الروسيه
في بحر اليابان ماذا تقول خطه واشنطن
وتوكيو بشان اي صراع صيني حول تايوان ما
مستقبل الامن في منطقه المحيط الهادئ في
ضوء تنام التوتر وازدحام مياهه بالحضور
العسكري
[موسيقى]
سين صديقه حميمه لبوتين تدريبات
التحرير الحمايه الممرات
والاستراتيجيه البحريه وكذلك هو من اجل
التعزيز الاستقرار والسلام في هذا المنطقه
وكذلك من اجل مواجهات اي تحديدات اتحاديات
امنيه المحتمله في المستقبل انا لا انا
استخدام
الطائرات مقاتله تحميله قنابل نوويه هو
ضمن القدرات الدفاعيه لو كانت فقط تقوم
بعمليات استطلاع لا باس بذلك ولكن حين
نستخدم هذه الاسلحه هذا يعني اننا نقوم
بمقاربه هجوميه وليس هدف دفاعيا لم تستخدم
اي يعني اسلحه نوويه فسين هناك دوره
الوحيده النوويه التي تتعهد بعدم
مبادره في استخدام الاسلحه النوويه يعني
هناك تخوف امريكي من الاجراءات الصينيه
والاجراءات الصينيه قد اضعها في بعدين
البعد الاول وهو الهيمنه والسيطره على بحر
الصين الجنوبي وتحويله الى بحيره صينيه
الصين الواحده تجعل من ممر تايوان مياها
اقليميه صينيه خالصه
هي الان دوليه عرض الممر مئه ميل وبالتالي
مقسم بين
جزء يتبع تايوان جزء يتبع الصين وجزء
يعتبر ممرا مائيا دوليا
[موسيقى]
الولايات المتحده قلقه من العسكره التي
تحصل في شمال شرق اسيا ليس فقط من قبل
الصين وروسيا ولكن ربما ايضا من كوريا
الشماليه هذا يقلقنا يقلق حلفائنا وتدفعنا
الى اتخاذ اجراءات الدفاعيه
العسكريه ومن اجل الدفاع عن
امنيه الوطني للصين
يعني تتماسك يعني السياسات الدفاعيه ذات
طبيعه الدفاعيه ما يقلق
ناه حره في مضيق تايوان ان 27% من السفن
التجاريه العالميه تمر بهذه المياه نحن
بحاجه الى حماياتها
بسبب الانفصاليون في تايلان او الذين
يسعون الى الاستقلال ودعم الامريكي لها
المصالح الرئيسيه الامريكيه تتلخص في منع
هيمنه الصين على الصين الجنوبي لجمله
اسباب اهمها موجودات النفط سبعه مليار
برميل 23 تريليون متر مكعب من الغاز
الممرات الرئيسيه واكثر واهم مرين في
العالم
ممرملكه
وممرائها نحن نتصرف ونتحرك دفاعا عن
النظام العالمي هناك مناورات اجرت القوات
الامريكيه معك جميع الدول في المنطقه فاذا
نظرنا الى السجل هذه المناوره نجدها
بالمئات خلال السنوات والعقود الماضيه
اليابان الاطلسيه واسره على الفلبين
وكوريا الجنوبيه
كل هذه الاطراف قد اعربت عن قلق فعلي من
ان تقوم الصين او تحاول القيام بنفس
مقامته او قامت به عفوا روسيا في اوكرانيا
يمكن لليابان ان تقدم المساعدات الاداريه
والخدميه ولكن اشارت اشارت لعبه الحرب الى
نقطه في غايه الخطوره اكبر قواعد عسكريه
امريكيه موجود في جزيره اوكيناوا ماذا لو
تم استهدافها من قبل الصين وبالتالي هنا
متدخل الصين اليابان عسكريه
يعني حريص مثل الصين يعني تحرص على السلام
والاستقرار في حاضر منها لان اذا حدث اي
يعني مواجهات مباشره ستدمر يعني
سددر بها المواطنين في الصينيون في
الجانبين
[موسيقى]
حشود عسكريه
امريكيه ثلاث اضعاف حجم القوه الامريكيه
في اوروبا يوجد مئه الف يوروبا يوجد 330
الف في جنوب شرق اسيا يوجد ثلاث حاملات
طائرات يوجد اكثر من 300 قطعه بحريه يوجد
و22 طائره شبحيه استراتيجيه يوجد اكثر
بستين طائره
تو
ستين
الوجود الامريكي العسكري كان مستقرا جدا
في المنطقه لدينا سين هي التي قامت
باجراءات عدائيه قامت بعسكره بحر جنوب
الصين ليس لدينا اي جزيره في به جنوب
الصين ولا ندعي اننا نسيطر على اي منها
القديم هو اكبر يعني السبب لتواتر في هذه
المنطقه
قبل اكثر من 70 سنه فعندما سين تحاول
التوحيد الكامل للبلاد فهو الاسطول
السابعه يعني وقف امام توحيد كامل
هو عمل مدمر وخطير على الجميع
وليس في مصلحه الصين تريد ان تدرك
الولايات المتحده الاستمرار في تزويد
الاسلحه في هذه المنطقه
ستجعل الشعوب يعني هذه المنطقه
يجلسون على يعني متفجرات وتدافعوا هذه
المنطقه الى المواجهه والتدمير